[Music]
unlike earth which is orbiting the Sun
there are billions of rogue planets
roaming the Milky Way not bound to any
host star one of them has been spotted
on the edge of our solar system what if
this interstellar object swung through
it how would this space invader affect
the orbits of the planets could it
possibly push earth out of the habitable
zone this is what if and here's what
would happen if a rogue planet entered
our solar system if a planet doesn't
belong to any star system it's
considered a rogue planet this is an
interstellar planet with a catchy name
just 20 light-years away from us it's
nearly 17 thousand times the size of
Earth and has a powerful magnetic field
that makes the planet glow with
incredible Aurora's what if this massive
alien planet trespassed the borders of
our solar system would this mean the end
of life here on earth
once the interstellar planet invaded our
solar system things could go very wrong
this rogue planet would likely be moving
at hundreds of kilometers per second if
we were unlucky enough to be on a
collision course with this massive alien
object the earth would be completely
demolished but don't worry our solar
system is quite big and the chances of
the rogue planet bypassing us without a
fatal collision are pretty high instead
our interstellar guest would be busy
disturbing the orbits of all the planets
in the solar system that's because a
rogue planet nearly 13 times bigger than
Jupiter would have a huge gravitational
impact making other planets orbits
including Earth's more elliptical and
that's when the bad news begins for life
here on earth the earth is orbiting the
sun's relatively narrow habitable zone
within this zone also known as the
Goldilocks zone it's not too cold so our
water doesn't turn to ice and not too
hot so it doesn't get vaporized and
neither do we
just perfect
change the Earth's orbit and the
conditions for life won't be so great
the rogue planet may not push us out of
the habitable zone but it would bring us
much closer to the Sun for very short
and exceptionally hot summers those
extreme summers would be followed by
long and super cold winters quick
summers would leave us less time to grow
crops by the end of our first
never-ending winter humanity could face
food shortages even extinction the earth
might be thrown into the next ice age
instead of global warming we'd be
worried about global cooling
we'd rethink our energy sources and try
to pump out more greenhouse gases to
warm the planet up a little solar energy
on the other hand would be considered
very inefficient in the wintertime but
could be used very effectively during
the short Blaze of summer count on
things being much worse if the earth
gets knocked out of the habitable zone
at that point the earth would
considerably cool down all our water
would freeze and so would we this would
be the end of most life on Earth the
only way we could survive would be if we
learn to live at the bottom of the ocean
next to deep-sea thermal vents that push
out extremely hot water maybe eventually
we'd evolve into a different life-form
that would take control over the frozen
planet lucky for us the universe is
enormous there's a lot of space between
rogue planets and other objects in our
galaxy and that makes this scenario very
unlikely but what if something did cause
us to evolve into another species well
that's a story for another what if
[Music]